fin fois merci on a pas du tout j'ai
désir que ary abittan était coupable on
relate des faits c'est le principe même
des journalistes que ça soit la presse
people que ça soit la presse se dit ni
grandioses ou ou propres comme le monde
non mais je vois la queue de la presse
propres comme on comme on dit dans le
jargon quand je veux dire les affaires
sur quand il l histoire sur gérard
depardieu s'était c'était le monde on a
eu de belles barres quand c'est quand le
parisien sort tous les détails de la
sphère de jean-luc là et on n'a pas ce
débat c'est le processus
par les films c'est le principe même de
la presse de révéler des choses là il
savait la croatie poehl qui le révèle on
relate des faits en aucun cas et moi
l'autre soir je n'ai jamais dit que ary
abittan était coupable j'ai dit ce dont
la plaignante présumé l'accusé après lui
la des avocats il peut par les voix sont
via son attaché de presse libre à lui
mais en aucun cas je me suis fait juste
je n'ai juste fait sa tournée des
zéniths oui je finis juste c'est juste
mon travail de journaliste ou j'ai
relaté des faits alors attendait d'abord
luzerner mans il ya une chose sur
laquelle vous avez raison il ya aucune
raison de s'en prendre juste la presse
people le monde mediapart etc il ya une
chose qui ne va pas du tout d'abord
c'est que les dossiers d'instruction
maintenant les pv de police et les
dossiers d'instruction se retrouve dans
la presse découpée en petits morceaux
avec chacun son mauvais goût avec un
nous sommes conviés dans les chambres à
coucher
ce dont nous ne voulons pas donc a pas
de raison d'incriminer plus la
présidence quand vous dites on a révélé
excusez moi vous avez lu des dossiers
d'instruction ça me paraît pas être un
travail ne fait pas le travail si on me
l'a eue on a les journalistes rendez
vous laissez parler vos médias ni le le
travail d'investigation de nous alors ne
connais pas le boat donc je ne vais
parler de ce que je connais ça consiste
quand même allé bouffer avec des juges
ou avec des flics et à balancer ce
qu'ils vous ont donné c'est quand même
pas c'est quand même pas sherlock holmes
à les récitations il suffit tout
simplement
non mais vous avez dit bien d'accord il
ya un problème ne s'était pas l'eau sale
[Rires]
merrett bien d'accord puis un petit
problème si vous voulez et je ne sais
pas comment on peut le résoudre moi je
ne suis pas sûr que le public doit être
informé en temps réel quand une plainte
est déposée
mais c'est effectivement dans le monde
des réseaux sociaux c'est compliqué mais
vous êtes bien d'accord que quand
quelqu'un est que ce soit lui ou
d'autres est à la une des journaux avec
une accusation si vous voulez que vous
êtes dans l'ambiance me to où toutes ces
féministes nous ont dit pendant tes amis
ni supposé présumés ces néo féminisme
nous ont dit pendant un an que dès
qu'ils avaient accusations il fallait
croire la parole des victimes et c'est
menace la cia a aucune femme qui était
menteuse méchante qui vous les étrangers
comme si j'avais pour être dans les 60
ans et plus et malgré tout malgré tout
je constate une chose c'est que dans les
plantes quand même très souvent si vous
voulez ce n'est pas des inconnus ces
défis qui accuse quelqu'un avec qui elle
avait eu une histoire c'est à dire même
dans cette affaire si j'ai bien compris
c'est une relation est consentie loutre
non alors excusez moi je veux dire les
relations amoureuses à nos yeux mais pas
forcément dans un cas récent de
suppositions les deux nations mais ses
positions dans cet article si on n'a pas
d'offrir à la jeunesse tient c'est que
d'abord effectué
des faits la presse people relate que
des faits et là vous avez tort c'est
qu'on cite pas juste à faire des
déjeuners avec des juges des policiers
alors été plus grande affaire
malheureusement dernières ont été sortis
par la presse people françois hollande
julie gayet mazarine pingeot d'une grand
mère les a sortis dont l'entente il
relate des faits et ne font que relater
des faits et les faits qui sur deux
roues sont des mois rien ne vous dis
juste que pour relater ces pays il
n'aura pas fallu un grand travail
domestique
travail dans la presse people vous avez
déjà fait des travail de jeu mais si
géniaux de brouilleurs la vente globale
il avait l'air assez de critiquer mais
c'est complètement ridicule comment
c'est vrai du faux de critiquer bien
mais on me dit que l'usaid salle jaune
ou y ait de bambi tout
débat donne la gerbe à ce point là me
tout d'abord et dont hublot inverse pas
cette expression se lance et crée sa vie
ou bien vous voulez savoir qu'une des
droits voulez savoir pourquoi je vous ai
de la famille que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord c'est l'affairé de tous je
voudrais pas très bien comment qu'on
compare ça vous intéresse que j'aurais
primer l'intérêt juste de continuer à ne
pas de l'acacia les y jouissent le
sichuan a tendance à regarder le mois
tout de suite j'ai tjrs laquelle vous
répond
alors je vais vous répondre ce que je
n'aime pas 1 je trouve que c'est très
bien d'accord que les agresseurs soient
punis dans les formes de la justice ce
que je n'aime pas c'est un mouvement qui
fait que toutes les femmes seraient des
victimes et on confond la transgression
qui est le fait d'une minorité
évidemment avec la norme on nous
explique que c'est systémique qu'il ya
une culture du viol et moi j'ai envie de
défendre les hommes géant vite des
pommes les hommes qui peuvent être
accusés à n'importe quel moment la
demande et aussi les femmes quand elles
sont agressés narcisse et elle me
réalisés dont le maire denis lavant fait
donc oui je suis là pour le faire va me
dire que moi je peux défendre les salles
et vous voulez défendre que moi le dépôt
qui je veux d'abord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ça fait trois ans où ça fait deux ans
que tous les jours on nous explique que
les hommes sont des [ __ ] que les
hommes sont les créateurs qui viennent
culte avant la culture du viol ça ne
veut rien dire finir on l'avait kkb y
est et le kasaï vous avez vous lu
decobert a été accusé de viol il a
d'ailleurs il a été innocenté et
d'ailleurs il faut dire les choses à la
gloire de la france c'est qu'en france -
qu'en amérique une fois vous étiez nos
santés philippe caubère remonte sur les
planches bientôt et je m'en félicite
richard berry geoffroy remonte bientôt
sur les planches oui voilà les mosans
félicité vraiment félicite aussi mail
s'il n'empêche si vous voulez que quand
vous avez une réputation quand vous avez
je ne sais pas par exemple qui se
passerait dans cette émission si ça
arrivait à l'un des chroniqueurs qui
sont autour de cette table d'accord je
ne sais pas ce qui se passerait même
s'il est innocenté ou même si a pas de
français parce que comme nato expliqué
l'an dernier que la justice ça se
faisait sur les réseaux sociaux que tu
peux donc balancer des accusations sur
les réseaux sociaux et que voilà c'est
fini c'est la justice et bien non on a
mis deux cents à trois cents ans à
construire une justice dans des formes
présomption d'innocence secret de
l'instruction
tout ça est balayée 6 voulais au nom du
caire sur les réseaux sur les réseaux
sociaux voulait donner raison oui non
bah oui bien sûr mais là pour le coup
c'est moi je suis très content qu'elles
défendent les hommes suis très contente
qu'elle défende défend les femmes voilà
on les laisse a raison de défendre aussi
les journalistes et le métier du
journaliste parce que c'est vraiment là
tu ce que vous dites c'est de remettre
en cause même le métier même de jeunes
des deux journalistes de relater des
faits qu'ils soient de personnes connues
comme de personnes a connu pas bon de
lui un jour d'une affirmation
m'émerveiller débile
[Rires]
sont débiles mais parce que moi vous me
dites c'est je parle pas évidemment des
gens inconnus je fais de la presse
people quand on fait du fait divers dans
le parisien on parle d'affaires aussi de
gens inconnus on révèle aussi les choses
car ok c'est le métier même de
journaliste que vous remettez en
question alors ne soyez maria fait
l'ancien journaliste doit être à l'abri
de toute critique selon non mais là pour
le coup la clé je suis un bizarre alors
qu'il est souvent n'investit pas
beaucoup je n'ai pas lu votre journal
donc je ne tiens pas du vôtre en juin on
arrive alors très bien moi je pense que
curieusement c'est là peut-être la
première fois que suis d'accord avec
elisabeth lévy pascal a raison alors
évidemment d'arriver votre ami d'eau non
ça n'a rien à voir avec ça elle a raison
dans ce qu'elle a dit en revanche les
magazines people qui affiche ce genre de
choses je comprends aussi puisqu'il ya
une demande d'information c'est
médiatisé les réseaux sont là mais elle
a raison
c'est moi les infos que la une est
abondant travailler dans l'émirat samuel
la ft la frères depardieu tourne en rond
faut arrêter vous salue dans l'ordre et
non durable c'est vrai ça donne
l'information sur moi c'est forcément
pas la presse people de le dire parce
que je pense que au tube ils devraient
être informés autrement mais par dire
par des vrais des vrais je reçois chez
les bretons
2e le maximum et que la presse people
c'est un journal insee ça y est bien sûr
mais je pense qu'effectivement il sort
sur lui paie là la terre mieux qu'on a
fait de vous cette semaine dans public
il devait sortir vendredi
vous auriez pu mettre présumé innocent
alors une exécution la menace et si on
vous donnait une information mais vous
savez pas si vous allez en donner des
tonnes et des tonnes d'aidé américain
savait très bien que c'est ça qui va
vendre donc vous continuez à chaque fois
c'était ça qui est n'importe quoi je
l'aimais leur a mis en jeu les mii en
accro de coûts donc arrêter de dire que
je veux faire vous allez en l'absence de
réformes et ce quel que soit mon actrice
dans les non-dits crise le système
et lampard nous aussi tout donner pour
en parler aussi pavillon en amont
participent tous la presse people la
sphère médiatique et la tension monte et
le public suit aussi le choix du fenua
d'accord là dessus tu as aidé à le vrai
problème oui le long raid en raison j ai
créé de l'instruction le vrai problème
c'est la suite à la base et après la
presse people fraiser donnant le nom la
guerre n'en pourrait problème bien il ya
un problème que dantesques et bien subi
tout au monde yens cellule
d'investigation je ne sais pas combien
de journalistes qui ne s'occupe que de
ça et dans cette ambiance si vous voulez
on nous a dit même le défenseur des
droits je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte le défenseur des droits dits acp
dans les affaires sexuelles il faut en
finir il faut renoncer à la présomption
d'innocence mais c'est incroyable